submission accomplished now earlier this
morning get the scientists at NASA they
all celebrated the culmination of an
epic journey that spanned three billion
miles it took nearly ten years well at
around look at that at around 7:40 9:00
a.m. Eastern the New Horizons spacecraft
performed the first ever flyby of Pluto
to the closest we've ever come to the
solar system's last unexplored planet
and here we are yes and you know I just
wanted to make sure you know the name
Pluto was given to it by suggested by an
11 year old girl it took place in March
and 1930 she was having breakfast with
her parents they were Rita her
grandfather was reading her the
newspaper about the discovery of the new
planet and she was studying Greek
mythology and she said Pluto and her
grandfather talked to a friend of his
who was at an astronomy professor at
Oxford University they were attending a
Condon he called the the group together
and said I suggest this for the people
in Flagstaff Arizona which is where they
have the observatory the Lowell
observant of the American public right I
mean that was there a puppy cartoon
character named Pluto yes and the other
grand thank you yes Neil deGrasse Tyson
right Tyson who was part of the original
group of scientists who demoted Pluto to
a dwarf planet Pluto facts I wrote the
Pluto files book in recovery after years
of hate mail from schoolchildren the
world over and he has been tweeting up a
storm about this trip because he is
excited about this it is still a dwarf
planet you know technically speaking but
it's also you know it's also clearly an
incredible feat yes we have visited a
source of inspiration